Arthur, does it help have someone to talk to?
My mother always tells me
to smile and put on a happy face.
She told me I had a purpose
to bring laughter and joy to the world.
Stop them!
Is it just me
Or is it getting crazier out there?
♪Smile
♪though your heart is aching
♪even though it's breaking
♪When there are clouds in the sky
♪you'll get by
What?
♪If you smile
♪through your fear and sorrow
♪Smile
♪and maybe tomorrow
Ahahahaha....
What's so funny?
Freak!
Gotham's lost its way.
What kind of coward would do something that cold-blooded?
Someone who hides behind a mask.
I used to think that my life was a tragedy.
But now I realize
it's a comedy.
If you just smile, ...